so I have an interesting equation here
it says V to the negative 6/5 power
times the fifth root of V is equal to V
to the K power for V being greater than
equal to zero and what I want to do is
try to figure out what K needs to be so
what is what is K going to be equal to
so pause the video and see if you can
figure out K and I'll give you a hint
you just have to leverage some of your
exponent properties all right let's work
this out together so the first thing I'd
want to do is is be a little bit
consistent in and how I write my
exponents so here I've written it as
negative 6/5 power and here I've written
it is a fifth root but we know that the
fifth root of something we know that the
fifth root the fifth root of V that's
the same way that's the same thing as
saying V to the 1/5 power and the reason
I want to say that is because then I'm
multiplying two different powers of the
same base two different powers of V and
so we can use our exponent properties
there so this is going to be the same
thing as V to the negative 6/5 times
instead of saying the fifth root of V I
can say times V to the 1/5 power is
going to be equal to V to the K it's
going to be equal to V to the K power
now
if I if I'm multiplying V to some power
times V to some other power we know what
the exponent properties would tell us
and I could remind us I'll do it over
here if I have X to the a times X to the
B that's going to be X to the a plus B
power so here I have the same base V so
this is going to be V to the and I can
just add the exponents V to the negative
6/5 power plus 1/5 power or neither V to
the negative 6/5 plus 1/5 power is going
to be equal to V to the K is equal to V
to the K I think you might see where
this is all going now so this is going
to be equal to V
so negative 6/5 plus one-fifth is going
to be negative 5/5 or negative one so
all of this is going to be equal to
negative one and that's going to be
equal to V to the K so K must be equal
to negative one and we're done K is
equal to negative one